Você já ouviu falar que o ZPMI causa
câncer de tireoide, que paralisa o
estômago, que dá pensamento suicidas,
mas também já viu médicos dizendo que
tudo é exagero, que a droga é segura? E
aí, quem que tá certo e quem que tá
errado? A resposta é: depende, porque
existe o que é real e confirmado, o que
é exagerado pela mídia e mais
importante, o que está sendo
negligenciado. Ninguém fala. Hoje eu vou
destrinchar tudo isso para você, sem
defender a droga cegamente e sem
demonizá-la injustamente.
Primeiro vamos falar do que é
absolutamente real e confirmado pela
ciência. Efeitos gastrointestinais. Isso
não é exagero. Uma revisão com mais de
2.000 pessoas mostrou que cerca de 40%
dos usuários de GLP1 reportam algum grau
de náusea, vômita ou diarreia. é a
classe do monjaro. Esse é o efeito
colateral mais comum e mais bem
documentado. Na maioria das vezes é
transitório, melhora com o tempo, mas em
alguns casos não melhora. E aqui entra a
gastroparia, que é a famosa paralisia do
estômago. Em janeiro de 25, o FDA
atualizou a bula do Zenpique para
incluir um aviso de que a medicação não
é recomendada para pacientes com
gastroparesia grave. Um estudo grande
identificou que um em cada 20 usuários
obesos ou diabéticos pode desenvolver
algum grau de retardo no esvazeamento
gástrico e o risco é quase quatro vezes
maior comparado a outras medicações para
emagrecer. Na maioria dos casos, os
sintomas melhoram ao parar a droga, mas
existem relatos de gastroparesia
persistente por meses ou até anos,
especialmente após o uso prolongado.
Outro efeito real e bem documentado,
problemas de vesícula biliar. Uma
metaanálise publicada no Jama Medicine
mostrou que o uso de agonistas de LP1
aumenta em 37% risco de doenças
biliares, incluindo cálculos e
colecistite. E quando usado para
emagrecimento em doses altas, esse risco
praticamente dobra. O mecanismo é
simples. Perda de peso rápida, aumenta a
secreção de colesterol pelo fígado,
altera a composição da bil e como a
pessoa come menos e com menos
frequência, a vesícula fica parada,
forma lama biliar, forma pedras. Agora,
um dos efeitos mais negligenciados e que
deveria estar no centro da discussão, a
perda de massa muscular. Uma metaanálise
dezembro de 24, publicado no
metabolismo, analisou 22 ensaios
clínicos e descobriu que aproximadamente
25% do peso perdido com esses remédios
vem de massa magra e com semagrutida em
dose alta, esse número pode chegar a
45%.
No estudo Step 1, os participantes
perderam em média quase 7 kg de músculo.
Isso é muito particularmente preocupante
para pessoas acima de 60 anos. O
envelhecimento natural já reduz a massa
muscular em 12 a 16% por década.
Adicionar uma perda muscular induzida
por droga pode empurrar a pessoa para
sarcopenia, fragilidade, risco aumentado
de quedas e fraturas. Um editorial
recente alertou que adultos acima de 65
anos são especialmente vulneráveis e tem
o famoso Ozenique Face. Esse termo foi
cunhado pelo dermatologista Paul Jud
Frank para descrever a aparência
envelhecida com bochechas encovadas,
pele flácida e rugas que aparecem após a
perda de peso rápida com essas
medicações. Não é um efeito direto da
droga, é consequência de perda de
gordura subcutânea facial. Mas o ponto
é, o médico que prescreve raramente
avisa sobre isso. A pessoa emagrece 20
kg e de repente parece ter envelhecido
10 anos. Queda de cabelo também real.
Estima-se que de 25 a 33% dos usuários
experimentam algum grau de queda. É uma
condição chamada efluvio telógeno,
causada pelo estresse metabólico de
perda de peso rápida. Geralmente é
temporário, resolvem três a se meses
após estabilização do peso, mas para
quem está passando é angustiante. Agora
vamos ao que está sendo exagerado.
Câncer de tireoide. Sim, em ratos, a
tirepatida onjaro e a semaglutida o
zenpicque causaram aumento dose
dependente de tumores de células
cedatireoide. Por isso, existe uma
contraindicação formal para pessoas com
histórico pessoal ou familiar de
carcinoma, medular de tireoide. Mais em
humanos até agora os dados são
tranquilizadores. Uma metaanálise 2024
analisou três ensaios clínicos com mais
de 13.000 participantes e não encontrou
aumento de risco de câncer. Os estudos
inumanos têm duração de 26 a 72 semanas,
então não sabemos o que vai acontecer em
10 ou 20 anos, mas dizer que o Zenque
causa câncer com evidência atual é
alarmismo. Pancreatite. Existe um aviso
na bula sobre pancreatite aguda,
incluindo casos fatais, mas os números
reais são baixos, cerca de 23 casos por
1000 usuários por ano. É um risco que
existe, deve ser monitorado, mas não é a
epidemia que algumas manchetes sugerem.
Depressão e pensamentos suicidas. Aqui a
história é complicada. O FDA está
investigando após relatos no sistema de
fámacovigilância. Foram identificados
262 casos de ideiação suicida entre mais
de 25.000 relatos de eventos adversos e
houve 20 suicídios reportados. Mas isso
é importante. Um estudo grande
financiado pelo INIA, publicado no
Nature Medicine encontrou que a
semaglutida está associada a uma redução
de 49 a 73%
no risco de suicida comparado a outras
medicações para obesidade ou diabetes.
Os dados são conflitantes. Uma possível
explicação é que os trials clínicos
excluíram pessoas com histórico
psiquiátrico. Então, não sabemos como a
droga se comporta nessa população.
Agora, o que está sendo sistematicamente
negligenciado? Primeiro, o efeito
rebote. O estudo de extensão do step 1
mostrou que um ano após pararse uma
aglutida, os participantes recuperaram
2/3 do peso que tinham perdido. 2/3. E
dados do mundo real mostram que quase
20% das pessoas recuperam todo o peso ou
mais em 12 meses após descontinuar.
Então a droga não ensina o seu corpo a
se autorregular. Ela suprime
artificialmente a fome. Quando você para
a fome volta com força. Segundo
deficiências nutricionais silenciosas.
Como a pessoa come muito menos, ela pode
desenvolver deficiências de proteína,
ferro, zinco, vitamina D e B12. Os
médicos que monitoram de perto relatam
que pacientes super respondedores
simplesmente param de comer
adequadamente. Isso contribui para queda
de cabelo, paraa perda muscular e paraa
fadiga. Terceiro, mudanças na função
tiroidiana. Um estudo de 2024 mostrou
que 3 meses de semaglutida reduziram
significativamente os níveis de T3
livre. O T3 é o hormônio tiroidano ativo
que regula seu metabolismo. Essa redução
pode não ser clinicamente significativa
em todo mundo, mas em uma pessoa que já
tem metabolismo lento pode fazer
diferença e alguns efeitos não revertem
completamente após parar a droga.
Quarto, efeitos na função sexual. Esse é
um tema que quase ninguém discute, mas a
literatura científica está começando a
documentar. Uma análise 2025 publicada
no International Journal of Importance
Research. encontrou a associação entre
agonistas de LP1 e disfunção sexual
masculina nos dados de
fármacoviligilância
do FDA. Um estudo da Cleveland Clinic
com mais de 4.000 pacientes mostrou que
1,24%
desenvolveram disfunção herétil nova
durante o uso. E há relatos de casos
publicados no sexual medicine de
mulheres desenvolvendo anorgasmia
completa. Uma paciente de 71 anos
recuperou a função apenas duas semanas
após parar a medicação. Os mecanismos
propostos incluem vaso constrição do
músculo liso genital que reduz fluxo
sanguíneo e modulação dos receptores
GLP1 no hipotálamo que pode diminuir
dopamina e noripinefrina
neurotransmissores essenciais para
desejo e prazer. Mas aqui tem um
paradoxo interessante. Em homens obesos
ou diabetes com testosterona baixa, a
droga pode melhorar a função sexual
porque a perda de peso aumenta a
testosterona. Então, sete de nove
estudos em uma revisão sistemática de
2025 mostraram esse efeito. Então,
impacto depende do estado metabólico
prévio da pessoa. Então, em quem já era
saudável pode piorar. Em quem tinha
disfunção metabólica pode melhorar. O
problema é que ninguém avisa isso antes
de prescrever. E o mais importante de
tudo, o elefante na sala, a droga não
trata a causa. Se a pessoa tem
resistência ulínica, compulsão
alimentar, inflamação crônica, disbiose
intestinal, deficiência de sono, a
semaglutida, mascara tudo isso. Ela
suprime os sintomas sem resolver a
fisiopatologia. E quando você para,
todos esses problemas a estão lá
esperando. A visão funcional não é
contra o uso dessas medicações, pelo
menos eu não sou. Em casos selecionados,
obesidade grave, risco cádiovascular
alto, falha de outras intervenções,
pessoas que estão sinceramente iniciando
melhora de estilo de vida, você pode sim
introduzir esses medicamentos, pode ser
uma ferramenta útil. O problema é quando
ela vira a primeira linha, quando tem
pessoas aí, médicos propondo tomar pro
resto da vida, quando substitui o
trabalho de base, quando é prescrito sem
acompanhamento nutricional e médico
adequado, sem treino de força para
preservar músculo, sem monitoramento de
micronutrientes, sem um plano de
transição para quando a pessoa vai
parar, porque um dia ela vai parar,
porque são remédios caros. Você merece
saber a verdade completa antes de tomar
uma decisão. Não a versão vendida pelo
laboratório, nem a versão alarmista da
mídia, a versão real. E já que estamos
falando de emagrecimento e metabolismo,
você precisa entender como a resistência
insulínica sabota qualquer estratégia de
peso de peso. Assista esse vídeo aqui
sobre cinometabólica que vai
complementar perfeitamente você aprendeu
hoje. Agradecimentos especiais aos
nossos membros queridos dos estudos
avançados da comunidade fechada do
YouTube. Começando pelos novos membros
que entraram recentemente, Coruja
Curiosa, Walter Salgado, Luciano Silva
Polinelli, Luciano Elias, Carlos Roveri,
Odonor Pinheiro, Cíntia de Assis
Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e Fernando
Machado. Sejam muito, muito bem-vindos.
Agradeço também aos membros que fizeram
upgrade pros estudos avançados. Coruja
Curiosa, Irma LC, Iana Medicina,
Adriane BMS, Dra. Ana Paula Rodrigues,
José Fortunato Murtinho, Sou Jucioli,
Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela
Mares Silva, Elô Terapias Integrativas e
Luís Anselmo Neves. Obrigado pela
confiança e elevar o nível de
participação. Um abraço especial aos
membros que retornaram à comunidade,
Alex Caldas, Marcelo Pimentel e Cláudio
Leitão. Que bom ter vocês de volta. Eu
quero fazer um reconhecimento especial
aos membros mais fiéis. Estela Mares com
57 meses de fidelidade, Dra. Ana Paula
com 45 meses, Marcelo Pimentel com 23 e
Elô Terapia Integrativas com 9 meses de
história conosco. A todos vocês eu
agradeço de coração pelo apoio
prestrado. Vocês fazem diferença nessa
comunidade.